I gave Biden money because when he went
in front of these coal miners I know how
to shovel coal you can learn how to
program a computer I'm like I need a
year of this he literally did to learn
to code me are you finding that there is
an undercurrent of support for Trump now
that did not exist last time that
suddenly this thing has gone so bananas
everything we've been talking about for
this half hour but now there's people
that would have never considered voting
for Trump the first time that basically
still see the wheels on the machines
still see some level of pride in America
still see paychecks that are working an
unemployment that's low in black
unemployment that's low and Hispanic on
implement that's low and they like
getting rid of some of the regulation
and all of those things that were not in
extra Wars and he's trying to get us out
of Afghanistan and everything else that
suddenly people that could would have
been completely in opposition to Trump
last time I think I'm not up there I
think a lot of them are just gonna be
happy to stay home they're gonna be like
look I can't bring myself to vote for
this guy he's you know we can think of
all the names but I'm not going to
endorse this especially if Biden is the
nominee I gave Biden money because when
he went in front of these coal miners I
know how to shovel coal you can learn
how to program a computer I'm like I
need a year of this he literally did to
learn to code me I mean for those people
that but but for people that know about
this meme this was a meme that when what
was it was at BuzzFeed when BuzzFeed was
gonna yes and they laid off a lot of
journalists yeah and and they're all
boo-hooing and then all the trolls in
the coach I used the word trolls in the
good sense yeah
added them a hashtag learned to code
yeah and people got kicked off with
Twitter meaning learn how to do
something productive right that of being
a BuzzFeed and bright and Biden actually
brought it to life but he also brought
to life it's an audience where it's not
accurate right it is if you know how to
write for BuzzFeed you could probably
have the technical skills to learn how
to code on a basic level right if you're
a coal miner that does not mean you know
how to use a computer well this is not
and by the way if you're computer
programmer
you can't mined coal either these do not
transition very easily so and I think it
was comfortably smug who tweeted out
that you do know if there's the debates
Trump is gonna bring that stripper and
put her in the front row and ask Joe if
he's met his granddaughter and it's
going to be just complete chaos so III
hope he's the nominee very desperately
but watching him
is sort of depressing right I know so I
know this is where you wouldn't it's
depressing in that for for someone
that's a little more old-school politics
and not on the fringe of the new right
yeah but for someone that like you know
I want the system to somehow function
even though I always tell you it's like
I love all the intellectual adventures
that go on with you I really do but for
someone that wants like some thing to
kind of hold that was somewhat centrist
and we could have an interest Biden no
but he can't do it anymore it seems like
he can't do it which is why he's telling
these guys to code it's why he's saying
you can pick your gender depending on
which jail you want to go to he said
that yeah at the Equality Forum someone
said it's not what birth sex you are
it's what you identify as you have an
awful lot of male rapists in women's
prisons he literally said that he was
brought in as the same guy and he can't
be sane but I think that gets to your
point that this thing just eats through
everything
yeah yeah right and I he again he
doesn't have that space within his party
I can't believe he said that about the
jails I mean this is hilarious but I am
not making it up how are you how are you
not how is this depressing to you this
is glorious I don't I can't telling my
guys right now we're gonna play the clip
right now in prison the determination
should be that your sexual identity is
defined by what you say it is not what
in fact the prison says it is and in
that case you should be entitled also to
OGB whining anyway you don't notice that
question because I'm likely to either I
guess well there you go malice that's
the man that you want to be the
Democratic candidate for president
desperately one of the things that this
speaks to is one of the best aspects of
conservatism which is asking questions
like what do you when you're advocating
for a program what do you do with the
people who will use this program in bad
faith or this law in bad faith and very
often people on the Left don't have an
answer or they'll hand-waving away like
oh there won't be that many cases well
that don't we that many cases again is
Nicholas Cruz in Florida shooting up a
school it's that outlier that both moves
culture and also is the destroyer and
that is who we should be concerned about
what else you tracking right now
what else is on your mind out of the
that's unearthed
I've been in the bottom of the internet
and well I've been so I've been engaging
in like psyops with a lot of these types
so for example when you're working on a
campaign you're going to have tunnel
vision bunk you're gonna you're living
in a bunker right so when there's an
article that comes out in The New York
Times every one the campaign is freaking
out how is this going to play how the
other campaigns you kind of have like
Plato's cave very limited information so
what I do is I have a bigger Twitter
following than many of these campaign
managers for these candidates so instead
people tweet like nasty things at them
that'll strengthen their resolve if
you're saying oh Warren's this and that
it's like yeah I'm fighting for her
against you so I will be like hey at
Roger Lau latest polls came out from
Iowa five of the six candidates have
solidified their support only Warren has
lost support how depressed are you at
the campaign on a scale of one to
Anthony Bourdain and then that gets
retweeted and you know it's filling up
his notifications and he's already
having a bad day and now he's going to
be freaking out even more hopefully so
your instead of killing them with
attacks it's not quite kindness you're
killing you're killing you're killing
them with sarcasm based on sarcasm
question I mean it other than I'm giving
the devil on their left shoulder
steroids and being like more insecurity
more fear more freaking out and just
ginning up that kind of I mean I can't
imagine working a campaign is in a state
of constant stress and and panic and
you're putting out fires all the time so
let's add some gasoline and watch it
burn how concern to you that the at the
social media level and the big tech
level that the game has been so rigged
and manipulated already that we have no
idea what's going on you know I keep
mentioning this thing about shadow
banning is now in Twitter's Terms of
Service okay they can literally throttle
accounts we've we've known sure that
they've been doing it forever but now
they're telling us they're doing it as
of January 1st and we all just keep
playing the game as if the game is not
being read but the game is always going
to be rigged I mean when you have your
enemies to expect them to play fair is
extremely naive this is my Soviet
mindset shocking we did have a president
who tweeted his way into the White House
and I think what people don't appreciate
is the existential angst it causes
someone who works at a social media
company
to see their product or their program
being from their perspective subverted
by those who they despise to further
their agenda this must cause them a lot
of grief but doesn't it also cause them
to you know tighten those pickets and
make sure that as we get closer to the
election that Mykel malice isn't gonna
be heard as much or Trump's not gonna be
heard as much or Rubin or anybody else
I'm sure I mean the thing we all pretend
that that's not really it like that
would be the thing that we would all be
relentlessly talking about right if I
mean really were trying to change
something here I think they are losing
tools in their toolbox and I think I
mean you know Kamla Harris you know was
calling for Trump to be banned from
Twitter remember this yeah and she got
pushed back even from the left and when
she lost her campaign I did a ham
tasting on my livestream and we tried
you know different kinds of hams from
all over the world because the pig was
finally roasted so I think they are
going to try different tactics but
because they're being called out on
their tactics instead of being called
out on the issues this is why they are
freaking out it used to be they would
say Dave Rubin is a racist and you would
spend months being of no I'm not no I'm
not
now it's Dave Rubin saying look at their
technique of calling me Rogen everybody
else a racist as a means of preemptively
dismissing them so by you calling out
their technique it loses almost all its
a thickest e you know it's funny because
like three years ago let's say when
daily beast or mother jones or any of
these awful things these these g what do
you call it you call them jihadist
jihadis without the testosteron yes
whenever they were doing then they would
call me all these things you know I'd
fight back and then you know I could
occasionally get them to change one line
or whatever but then they wouldn't they
wouldn't actually retweet the thing they
would just change it and nobody's seen
it and whatever it's out there it's out
there for them right stealth edit so
then Wikipedia can grab from it and
write and the rest of it but it used to
really upset me obviously when I first
you know like anyone that starts getting
that heat it yeah it's hot at first and
in a weird way now because I book coming
out in April and I know what that is
gonna cause that that microscope to look
at me or you know really fine-tune on me
is that I'm glad that I went through it
now yeah do you find that too that
you've been through a lot of the
the hips on this stuff and it's like
that actually makes you stronger now
oh and especially it makes my audience
stronger because they love it because
yeah because there's it's like a
greatest hits album right so it's
xenophobic racist homophobe hola I'm
from Brooklyn I'm an immigrant yeah I
mean so when they state when I went
after George Soros Oh could you talk
yeah talk about this this is a this was
this is exactly why I think you're such
a great thinker truly what what this
whole Soros thing oh it was beautiful so
some guy from the Atlantic and I'm not
trying to be dismissive about genuinely
don't remember his name yeah glad looks
pretty terrible these days they've been
put Dave they say this is where they're
terrible since Woodrow Wilson no I mean
even before in the nation I mean these
people were the ones agitating for World
War one I mean you have to go back so
they there is Rudy Giuliani made a
comment that he's more Jewish than
George Soros now in any other context if
you were talking to Jewish people and
said someone can be culturally Jewish
without actually having Jewish ethnicity
as opposed to someone could have Jewish
ethnicity and basically be a total [ __ ]
right this is not controversial this is
very well known and everywhere everyone
knows this Obama kept saying he was the
first Jewish president this is very
known we're both Jewish we know people
who are super Jewish and then people who
were basically lost and the people who
are adopted you is basically yeah I
would like the culture and the guy from
the Atlantic was like ah in the world of
Trump someone can be less Jewish
somebody else and he sang this about a
literal Holocaust survivor right
referring to Soros yeah but what was
amazing is in the same way it's Dave
Rubin comma secret Klansmen and
homophobe comma it's George Soros comma
literal Holocaust survivor now I always
say the corporate press is factual but
not truthful if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell